[Music]
[Music]
hey friends welcome to machine learning
experts i'm your host brittany muller
and today's guest is none other than
margaret mitchell
meg for short meg founded and co-led
google's ethical ai group
is a pioneer in the field of machine
learning has published over 50 papers
and is a leading researcher in ethical
ai
you're going to hear meg talk about the
moment she realized the importance of
ethical ai such a good story
how machine learning teams can be more
aware of harmful data biases
and the power and performance benefits
of inclusion and diversity in machine
learning
if you want to learn more about how
hugging face experts like meg can help
accelerate your machine learning roadmap
please go to hf dot co support or simply
google expert acceleration program to
learn more
so excited to introduce you to this
really powerful episode here is my
conversation with meg mitchell
meg mitchell thank you so much for
joining me today i really appreciate it
and is it okay if i call you meg or do
you prefer to go by margaret okay i just
want to make sure i publish as margaret
um yeah but yeah everyone
perfect perfect curious if you could
just speak a little bit about your
incredible background and experience and
what ultimately led you to your role at
hugging vase
yeah nice of you
yeah so
i can speak to my bachelors first
where i focused on linguistics
but i had
always really been interested in
programming and was like programming on
the side
from when i was a lot younger and so
by the end of my linguistics bachelors i
was doing
natural language processing work
sort of looking at generation in
particular so how do we take
some structured representation and
generate language from it like
describing scene
and then from there i ended up working
on
assistive technology for a while
i continued to work on assistive
technology
well i should say assistive and
augmentative as well as
methods for
automatic diagnosis
of different kinds of
neurological disorders so like
parkinson's
as well as
autism
so
that work was something that i then
continued throughout my master's and phd
so i would like go back in the summer or
whatever keep working on it for about
seven years
i ended up doing my master's in
computational linguistics at the
university of washington with emily
bender
who is really awesome and if you're not
aware of her work like i highly
recommend checking it out
and then from there i went on to do a
phd in computer science
where i worked with a hood writer
who's a little bit known in the
generation world at least
where i looked at how to generate
language from computer vision
and then from there i did some more like
heavy statistical work
as a postdoc at johns hopkins
and then from there i went to microsoft
research where i continued doing
vision to language generation
i combine that with my interest in
assistive technology by working on
an app for people who are blind to be
able to navigate the world a little bit
more easily
which is a product called seeing ai
which microsoft still offers which is
cool
and then after a few years there
i went on to google
as a sort of new chapter of my life
to focus on
what was increasingly becoming
an issue in
machine learning which is
the big data problems that are inherent
in deep learning
so around 2011 2012 massive uptick in
deep learning which also meant a massive
uptick in really problematic things that
models were picking up from large data
so that's when i started focusing on
things like fairness
rigorous evaluation for different kinds
of issues and bias issues
and that ended up kind of
spinning into this organization at
google
focusing on machine learning fairness
and i was able to get a group of people
who were excited about what i was doing
as a team and we became the ethical ai
team focusing on like inclusion and
transparency and all these related
issues
and then i was joined
by my co-lead tim nikka brew
and together we were able to build up a
much larger team where we had
someone with a background in sociology
people who were
more maybe interdisciplinary
sort of technical as well as
uh social science sort of
work
and then
from there that was about that was four
years
from there i went to hugging face
i
i was able to
jump in and just focus on coding which
after
so many years of the higher level stuff
i was just really
aching to just code
and not be in meetings not lead anything
like i just wanted to be like a computer
scientist
so so they kindly let me join and like
just code
for a while and now
in in this year 2022
i'm i'm helping a lot more with building
up protocols for inclusive hiring and
the stuff around setting up a good
culture that is you know inclusive and
diverse
as well as like nlp tasks and helping to
expand to computer vision
and yeah and that brings us to now
that's incredible i love
hearing
you know experts and professionals like
you who have this extensive background
that still just love being in the weeds
and loving yeah program yeah and then
yeah i love that that's my that's my
happy place definitely
yeah
it's important it's important to you
know funnel that
right yeah
that's so cool i'm curious so throughout
that experience
if you can pinpoint
the moment in which you
discovered
the importance of data ethics and ethics
and machine learning
yeah
yeah so this is when i was
at microsoft
working on the assistive technology
working on seeing ai
in general i was working on
generating language from images
and what i was starting to see
was just how
just how i would guess i would say
lopsided data was
just they just it data just really
represents a subset of the world as it
is and it really influences what a model
will say
so
i was starting to run into issues where
white people would be described as
people and black people would be
described as black people
so like as if white was a default and
black was a marked
character um characteristic
so
that was concerning to me
there was a there was sort of an aha
moment where i
was feeding my system
a sequence of images getting it to talk
about more of like a story of what's
happening
and i fed it some images about this
massive blast
at a factory
where a lot of people worked it was
called the hempstead blast
and you could see from the sequence of
images
that the person taking the picture
was on like the second or third story
looking out at the blast and the blast
was very close to this person and you
could see there was the news on in the
corner and it was like talking about the
blast and the view from the news was
basically like the same view that this
person had
so it was just like this really dire
intense moment
and i i fed it through the system and
the system was like this is awesome this
is a great view this is beautiful and
you're like
it is a great view
of this horrible scene right but what's
important here is that people might be
dying this is a massive destructive
explosion yeah the thing is when you're
learning from images people don't tend
to take pictures of horrible things
people think images of like going to
parties like having fun sunsets things
like that so it had learned like oh i'm
looking at the sky i see like blue and
red like it's beautiful
and it just really struck me that that
was just one hop away from a system that
would potentially blow up buildings
because it thought it was beautiful
right you give something with that sort
of thinking
access to actions and now things can be
yeah
so that was really a moment for me where
i realized i didn't want to keep making
these systems do better on benchmarks i
wanted to fundamentally shift how we
were looking at these problems how we
were approaching data and analysis of
data how are we evaluating and all of
the factors that we were leaving out
with just these straightforward
pipelines
so that really became the shift to
ethical ai work
wow that is a very powerful example
i'm sure you've seen so many sense
and what applications is data ethics
most important yeah yeah so it's in
human-centric technology yeah so
human-centric is technology
that
that deals with people so envision it's
things like face recognition pedestrian
recognition all of these things that
have to do with classification detection
and recognition of people
in in natural language processing it has
to do
with things like
privacy of individuals how individuals
are talked about and the biases that
models pick up about
the descriptors used for different
people
so you know if you're just talking about
random objects or things like that
there's not as much of a risk of
personal harm because there isn't
personal things involved it's not people
and so across the board
regardless of the technology
it's when we start dealing with people
and specifically
identity
that that some of the most massive
issues come up with the highest
potential for harm
that makes sense yeah
interesting how
how can teams using
machine learning be more consciously
aware of some of that you know
potentially harmful bias that's going on
well i think part of it is
just
that
these kinds of concerns haven't
generally been taught in computer
science
and so a lot of people just aren't aware
of the issues and if they were they
would care more that's that's definitely
true for a lot of people
there's
a lack of
knowing the kind of lexicon like how to
talk about things so you have a sense
sometimes that there's a problem
but you don't necessarily have the
vocabulary to talk about what that is
and then that can be a barrier
to
well first to like contextualizing
what's going on but also to
communicating with others about these
kinds of issues
and so i found that a lot of what ends
up helping people is simply having a
lexicon
like
like this is what marginalization is
this is what a power differential is
this is
how that becomes relevant in terms to
discrimination
that can come from a system here's how
stereotypes work here's what inclusion
is here's what diversity is this is the
difference between them
and so having a bit of more of a lexicon
and an understanding of some of the
pillars ends up being really helpful
and i think another issue is just the
culture around machine learning
and deep learning in particular
has
has tended to take a bit of a
sort of alpha or maybe macho approach
for for lack of a sort of better word
where
the focus is really on beating right so
you want to beat
the last numbers
you want to make things faster and
bigger and you know there's lots of
parallels that can be made to like human
anatomy or whatever
like oh yeah it's bigger that's better
definitely
but
and there's like a very sort of hostile
competitiveness that comes out where you
often find that women disproportionately
are treated less than
and since women are often much more
familiar with discrimination
women often are focusing a lot more on
ethics which and things around prejudice
and stereotypes and sexism
which means it gets associated with
women
more
and it gets
it's seen as less than
so so the culture is really really
difficult to penetrate sometimes
i definitely um
not someone it's generally not assumed
that i'm technical
it's something that i sort of have to
prove over and over again but i'm called
a linguist or i'm called an ephesus
because these are things i care about
and no
but that's treated as less than you know
you don't program you don't know about
statistics you are not as important
and it's often not until i start talking
about things statistically or
programming things or whatever that
people do take me more seriously which
is unfortunate
but yeah there's really a massive
cultural barrier there as well
oh you make so many good points in that
and
i've noticed that and we've heard renee
brown talk about that recently on her
podcast where yeah she's deeply offended
when people refer to her as a
motivational speaker and not a scientist
like she's a researcher she is an
academic in the fact that
we you know you have to even prove that
yes so yeah painful and ridiculous
yeah i'm regularly called an ethicist
and i'm a computer scientist uh i'm
flattered that like all of you know like
the ethical studies that one has to do
to be an ethicist is being imbued in me
like that's very flattering it also
might be kind of offensive to ethicists
but there's definitely just that
assumption there and i think it's
especially when you're a woman
that it really it really comes to comes
to a head where you're it's like they
don't want to see you as technical or
something like that or they don't want
to see you as a scientist or something
like that so it becomes
yeah yeah really difficult
and to your point they
most men in the field won't pick up on
the biases as quickly as women might i
know i'm just a very novice machine
learning hobbyist but there's been
models where i will feed pictures of
myself and they've cut my butt off and
put a cell phone wallet in my back
pocket as if i'm a man wearing jeans
right
yeah very interesting you know yeah yeah
and that's partially a function of of
the people who are developing the
technology you know they're just not
they don't have the world of being a
woman in their heads and so they miss a
lot of that stuff
and you know it's it's true for people
with marginalized characteristics in
general so
one of the close friends i made at
google was a black man and part of why
we became close was because we could see
the patterns of marginalization that was
happening to the other that no one else
saw
so we would see that one another were
often being left off of emails where we
were the most qualified person to be on
that email
kind of thing where if you bring up
you're sort of called a complainer or
whatever
but he and i both had the life of
experiencing this kind of stuff so we
saw this happening to one another we
were able to stand up for one another
yeah things like that it's it's just
something that a lot of people miss
unless they've had experience with
discrimination
yeah that's a great point i'm curious
you know i think it's so important to
have advocates especially you know
internally at organizations that size
are there any other things that
you know people minorities and
different people just experiencing those
sorts of
kind of you know subtle
discriminatory acts can do to
to better you know be effective in their
role and
make things a bit more fair
yeah
so i think this is where the
understanding of inclusion really comes
uh into play
and uh
so just to
kind of ground this
diversity would be when you have a lot
of different races ethnicities genders
ability statuses at the table
inclusion is when each person feels
comfortable talking they feel welcome
and and one of the best ways to be
inclusive is to not be exclusive
i think that's
fairly obvious and yet it's completely
missed where there's kind of like this
very exclusionary behavior that happens
you know we don't want this person in
the meeting because we don't find them
helpful which is a function of already
biases or because we find them annoying
or aggressive or combative which is also
a function of various biases
and there tends to be this
this push towards being exclusionary and
in a bunch of ways where we can create
more inclusive spaces as soon as we
realize that
to be inclusive you have to not be
exclusive and so what that means
you know very concretely
is if you are creating a meeting and a
bunch of people pay attention to the
demographic makeup
of the people you're inviting if your
meeting is all male
it's a problem
but you'll find
you know in tech a lot of meanings are
all male and if you bring it up
that
can be met with a lot of hostility
so i think it's about understanding that
there are strategies here
literally looking through thinking
through the demographics and making sure
that
each associated woman each associated
black person
you know latin next person
that is relevant to the project is also
included i like to say air on the side
of including people
especially when it comes to marginalized
characteristics it's much better to have
someone
who
who might not be as relevant
than to exclude someone who is relevant
so erring on the side of inclusion
when i was first trying to sort of train
my head to be
less biased i mean we're all
we're all biased in our own ways we all
were raised with cultural norms that
really affect how we perceive things
and so part of how i've tried to break
those patterns
is like i spent a good year probably
whenever i wrote an email
i would look at everyone who was in the
two and in the cc
and i would go through in my head their
genders and ethnicities and things like
that
and if i noticed that we were
that it was
sort of non-representative
of all the people working on the problem
i would fix that but it took like
concretely thinking about what are the
important characteristics that tend to
be marginalized
and then now i am going to unmarginalize
them
or unmarginalize the people with those
characteristics
so it's a very conscious effort
and that's something that
you know i guess depending on the
culture that people have been brought up
in they're more or less
um
interested in in doing
i think in the us there has been a good
response to that kind of approach
i'm less sure
in in france which is like also very you
know where hugging face is how much
that's appreciated
but at least at least in the us like
that kind of very intentional thinking
through demographics
helps and and people are are generally
responsive to that as long as you tell
them beforehand if you if you catch them
in the moments of like only preferring
majority characteristics like people get
very mad and defensive yeah so you know
as long as you mention it beforehand
that it's usually a lot better
that's a really great thing to be aware
of i'm curious to you know
i feel most of us at hugging base are
pretty
data centric and data aware and
i just i can't help but wonder and think
about isn't there proof
how inclusivity and diverse
individuals working on the singular
project produce
more successful outcomes yeah yeah yeah
since you have i mean minimally since
you have different perspectives you have
a just a different distribution over
options and you have more options
and so you know one of the fundamental
things about machine learning is like
how you should start training whether
you want to use some you know randomized
starting point
and what kind of distribution you want
to sample from
and
most people agree that you don't want a
sample from this one little piece of the
distribution in order to have
the best chances at finding like
like a you know an optimum like a local
optim
so
that's understood in machine learning uh
so it's just sort of you need to
translate that to the people at the
table like just how you want to have
this like gaussian sort of
approach distribution over different
kinds of start states so too do you want
that at the table when you're starting
projects because it gives you this
larger search space and makes it much
easier to get to some sort of local
optimum
absolutely i've never heard it explained
like that i think that is brilliant
yeah i think it's i think it's maybe
something that resonates with machine
learning people a little bit
a little bit more easily than saying
like you want different perspectives
oh my gosh i love that so much
so shifting a little bit onto some of
the incredible work you've done around
model cards i know this also stemmed
from this effort to
make models more transparent and i'm
just curious how
how did this particular project come
about
and you know where you see it heading in
the future
yeah so the model cards project first
started at google
i was when i first started i was working
on
things like fairness and what a rigorous
evaluation for fairness would look like
in order to figure out
what evaluation to use you have to have
a sense of
the context that the technology will be
used in
who could potentially use it both in
terms of your intended users and
malicious actors
because that really informs the kinds of
things that you want to evaluate through
ethical
and fairness lenses
and so i was working really hard on
building up
these kind of design documents for
how to approach model analyses
and it wasn't getting a lot of pickup
and then
around i forget the year i want to say
it was
late 2017
20 early 2018
i was talking to uh tim neat
who
was at that time someone else in the
field with similar interests to me
and she was talking about this idea of
data sheets where it's a kind of
documentation for data
based on
her experience
at apple doing engineering stuff where
you tend to have specifications of
hardware
but we don't have something similar for
data and she was just talking about how
crazy that is
and so she had this idea of data sheets
for data sets
and it really struck me that by
by having this idea of an artifact
suddenly that's something that people in
tech who are motivated for launches
would care a lot more about so right if
we say you have to produce this artifact
and even further you can launch that and
have it count as a launch then suddenly
people are incentivized to do it
so i thought a lot about taking the work
i was doing and then packaging it
similar to a data sheet to make it more
palatable in the tech world
and so then i was trying to think of
what is like a sin like not a synonym
what's a comparable word to data sheet
that could be used for models
i did want to do something that was
shorter in part because i was keying on
this idea of launches that people will
use and so i was like well it needs to
be shorter so i guess instead of a sheet
it's like a card
and then data model
and so her paper she was working on at
the time
to talk about data sheets was called
data sheets for data sets and so we
ended up calling ours model cards for
model reporting
and
then once we had the published paper
like everyone started taking it
seriously like both in terms of
internally at google and then
externally in in the tech world so
yeah i definitely would not have gotten
there if it weren't for tim neat's
brilliance of oh you need an artifact
you know you need to make this like a
standard thing that people want to
produce
right that's genius
yeah oh that's yeah
we also decided to call it model cards
because
there were a lot of things at the time
that could be used as words in the
fairness realm like fairness reports or
like transparency reports or whatever
but the more we talked about it the more
that seemed like something that would
soon be dated i really wanted to have a
generic term that like even if fairness
and ethics was something people didn't
care about anymore the fundamental idea
would persist
um so it struck me that like saying
model card as opposed to
some other stuff that came out
afterwards like transparency report like
those didn't catch on as much and i
think in part because they weren't
addressing this need to have it be
something very generic that would then
resonate no matter no matter what you're
working
right so that was also like a little bit
just just the name i think really helped
that is brilliant i've never thought of
that longevity of just the name itself
yeah yeah yeah
very cool i'm curious so where
do you see model cards headed in the
future
yeah so
there's a pretty big barrier to entry uh
for doing model cards in a way that's
well informed by ethics
in part because the people who
need to fill out these things are often
engineers and developers who want to
launch their model
they don't want to sit around and think
about ethics and like write up
documentation relevant
and so part of why i wanted to join
hugging face actually was because it
gave me the opportunity to start
standardizing how these things could be
filled out finding the patterns doing
sort of gap analysis
strengths and weaknesses
and starting to automate as much as we
can
and so one thing i really like about
hugging face is there's a focus on
how to create sort of end-to-end machine
learning development processes that are
as smooth as possible and so
i really wanted to
do something like that with model cards
where you could have something
largely automatically generated as a
function of different questions that are
asked or even just basics of the model
specification directly
so
i'm working towards and i think other
you know other people in the field are
working towards the ability to have
model cards that are as filled out as
possible and then
separately that are also interactive so
this was one of my last i guess big
projects at google was around creating
interactive cards where for example
you can see
the difference in the
false negative rate as you move the
decision threshold
so
normally with classification systems you
choose some threshold at which you say
yes or no
it's like 0.7
but in practice you actually want to
vary the decision thresholds in order to
trade off the different kind of errors
but that means having like a static
report
of how well it works uh
isn't actually something that is as
informative as you want it to be because
actually you want to know how well it
works as different decision thresholds
are chosen and actually theoretically
you could use that to decide what
decision threshold to be using with your
system
and so we created this model card where
you could like interactively change the
decision threshold and see how all the
numbers changed
and moving in that direction of further
automation and
interactivity
i think is definitely the way to go
that's brilliant and
i feel like that would be so powerfully
used in the future too just to have
better
awareness about those thrust thresholds
in general
right yeah some people like don't even
know that that's a thing when amazon
first started putting out facial
recognition and facial analysis
technology
it was found that like the gender
classification
disproportionately was bad for
black women
and amazon sort of responded to that by
saying like oh
this was done using the wrong decision
threshold
and then one of the police agencies
who had been using one of these systems
were asked what decision threshold they
were using and they said oh we're not
using a decision threshold which is like
oh you really don't understand how this
works and you're using this out of the
box with default parameter settings
that's a problem
like minimally having this documentation
brings people aware brings people like
brings people to be aware that
you have some decisions to make with
respect to the various type of
parameters
yeah that is a wild it continues to blow
my mind how often things are released
that haven't been run by these basic
kind of checks and balances
yeah yeah exactly blows my mind i
remember when the pandemic started i
wanted to record a podcast with my
friend who's a black woman and google
just released the google meet record
and so i talked her into i was like
we'll just use that it'll be super easy
and the entire recording is just of me
because it didn't it didn't recognize
when she was speaking
yeah i was so upset i couldn't believe
that was
even possible why didn't you test that
and it's it's the culture right it's
just not it's the people who develop
models often don't care about all those
other things and so they're just getting
out models getting out models and
they're not tested and
they're not explained
in terms of how they work in part
because no one knows because it hasn't
been tested
and that's so different than everything
else we put out
you know like toys and medicine and cars
right there's all these like strategies
of how you really test this to see if
this works and that just isn't there in
machine learning
in part because it's new so like the
laws and regulations don't exist yet
it's sort of like the wild west or
whatever but yeah that's part of what
we're trying to change by doing things
like model cards and data data sheets
and stuff
i'm curious if you can speak a little
bit more
to your day-to-day work at hugging face
and the
things you're working on
yeah
at this at this point i'm kind of all
over the place
so i'm working on a few different tools
so that's like coding as well as
design specifications for for other
engineers
i'm also working on
more
philosophical or social sciency kind of
research
so
i just did a deep dive into
udhr the universal declaration of human
rights and how those can be applied
within
artificial intelligence so i've been
doing more and more research that kind
of bridges gaps between ai machine
learning and
law and philosophy
and then i've also been
trying to develop
some statistical methods that are
helpful for
testing systems as well as understanding
data sets
so we recently put out a tool that was
just playing around with uh
showing how well the language mapped to
like zipfian distributions which
is how natural language
tends to tends to go
so you can test how well your model is
messing to natural language that way so
i've been working on those kinds of
things
and then also a lot on the cultural
stuff so spending a lot of time on how
to do hiring
and
what kind of processes we might have in
place to be
to be more inclusive and things like
that
and then also working on big science
which is uh this massive effort with
people you know throughout the world not
just hugging base
but within that i've been working on
data governance so
how data can be
used and examined without having it
proliferate all over the world
without it being tracked and how it's
used
so my day right now is just chaotic like
i'm just laughing
between each of these things and then
like occasionally i'll do an interview
or like i'll talk to a senator or
something
it's just like it's crazy it's all over
the place so you know i try and answer
emails sometimes that's part of my day
but i don't do it as much as i should
that is so funny it makes me feel a
little bit better hearing that from you
because that that is so the current
culture of the startup that is hugging
faces yes everybody wears lots of hats
exactly yeah yeah so it's just like
trying to trying to keep on top of all
these things and they're just so diverse
yeah that's incredible it was really
really sweet so i had interviewed louis
tunstall earlier today
and told him how i was going to be
speaking with you later this afternoon
and he spoke so highly of you everyone
at hugging face just adores you
and it's really nice to hear
i mean it's it's honestly like i feel
like you are such a bright light here at
the company and it was cool to hear it
from an engineering perspective like
louis because you know he had mentioned
how as a machine learning engineer and a
team full of some of the top
engineers in the world we're all aware
of data ethics we're all aware of bias
data but
meg has shown up and put this incredible
lens on it and shown us things and made
us more aware of things that we had no
idea and you know possibly been
overlooking and it was just he said in
the most powerful beautiful way i was
bummed i wasn't recording it because i
think that's the power that having you
and bringing
this experience and insight and
perspective to the table and it's
incredibly powerful so thank you
yeah thank you
and i asked him i was like well what
questions do you think i should make
sure and ask meg and he went to his
bookshelf he got a book that he's been
reading that you're featured in called
genius makers are you aware of this
oh yeah kade
yes yeah yeah
yeah he interviewed me for that
i i really
i thought it was very sweet of him
because he
interviewed me for it while i was at
google and google pr generally didn't
let me talk to anyone
when a journalist asked to talk to the
people working on ethics and fairness
they'd give like a vp
someone who actually wasn't working on
it but like was you know more
google representative or whatever but
kade knew me already he had already been
following my work and so he was like no
i want to talk to meg
yeah so he like
specifically was like if i want to know
more about this i talked to her like i
don't care what the other people are
saying so i was just like i was so
indebted to him for that and i was so
excited to be able to talk to him so i
ended up talking to him a lot more about
like my history and like working in
these different places
and then yeah that ended up being able
to make it into the to the book which is
really cool
i love that story i think it just speaks
volumes too of you know lewis was
mentioning this is
a historical ai book you know meg is a
legend
you have to be a part of that bigger
story
and play a role that's really nice yeah
i i was just so flattered and honored
that he he wanted to include anything i
had to say it was really cool
so i've got this last part of our
interview
where i go through rapid fire questions
okay
so uh best piece of advice for someone
looking to get into ai machine learning
best piece of advice uh
[Music]
i guess it depends who the person is
yeah um
i would i would maybe
it depends yeah if it's someone with
like marginalized characteristics or not
i would give very different advice if it
was a woman i would say don't listen to
like your supervisors telling you you're
not good at this
because everyone will get that or tons
of people get that don't listen to that
chances are you're just thinking about
things in a way that's different than
they're used to so
have have confidence in yourself
i guess if it's someone with more
majority characteristics i would say
like forget about the pipeline problem
pay attention to the people around you
and make sure that you hold them up too
so that the pipeline problem that you're
in right now
is less of a problem
and i guess i would also say evaluate
your systems
what are some of the industries you're
most excited to see machine learning
applied or machine learning ethics
applied
yeah most excited
well i guess the health domain and the
assistant yeah
continue to be areas that i care a lot
about and i see a lot of good potential
yeah
i also really really want to be able to
have systems that
assist people in terms of understanding
their own biases so like there's lots of
technology that's being developed for
like screening candidates for job
interviews and
things like that but really i feel like
the technology should be focusing on the
interviewer
and how they might be coming at the
situation with different biases and so i
would really love to have technology
that focuses more on
assisting humans to be more inclusive
as opposed to assisting humans to
exclude people
yeah
you that's one of my favorite part about
several of your talks and interviews is
your incredible examples of those
situations and one of my favorites was
you mentioned in a keynote how there was
a model created to detect
criminals
and they were able to identify the
pattern the mathematical pattern between
was it like the nose and the and the
edge of your mouth yeah the corner the
corners of the mouth yeah
yeah yeah and
like they were making this huge claim
that there was like this angle theta
that they discovered that was
more indicative of
criminals if it was a smaller angle but
like i was thinking about it and i was
looking at the math and i realized that
what they were describing was the
difference between a smile where you
have a wide angle and a straight face
where you have a much more narrow
hole and i was like wow they really
they really miss the boat on what
they're actually capturing there
that's so experimental
yeah wanting to find things that aren't
there should people be afraid of ai
taking over the world
there's a lot of things to be afraid of
with ai
i like to see it as we have a
distribution over different kinds of
outcomes
some more positive than others
so there isn't some set
at least not one that we can know
there are a lot of different things
where ai can be just super helpful super
assistive
possibly
task based as opposed to more general
intelligence
and you can see it going the other way
similar to
this example i had given about
um
thinking something destructive was
beautiful
like
that's one hop away from if the system
is able to like press a button or the
equivalent to press a button to like set
off a missile or whatever like yeah
so i don't think people should be scared
per se but i do think that they should
think about the worst ways that things
could go and the best ways that things
can go and aim for the best ways
and try and
mitigate
or stop the worst ways
i think the biggest issue right now is
just on how these systems can
can widen the divide between you know
haves and have not
really like further further give power
to people who have power and
you know further worse and things for
people who don't
as the people designing these systems
are often people with more power and
wealth and they design for
their kinds of interests
yeah so
i think that's the
the thing that's happening now and one
of the riskiest things
to be thinking about in the future
but ideally if if we can focus on what's
actually most beneficial
then we can lead it in that direction
exactly
yeah
what are some of your favorite machine
learning papers
um
well i would say most recently i really
loved uh
some of the work that um
honey has been doing around values uh
that are encoded in machine learning
um
my my own uh team at google has been um
or had been i guess
working on data genealogies
so really bringing
critical analyses into how machine
learning data is handled
and they have a few papers on that
um data and its discontents
i really love that work obviously i'm
biased but because it was like my team
like my my direct reports i'm like very
proud of them or whatever but but it's
really fundamentally good work i think
i'm trying to think of like earlier
papers those are those are very recent
papers i think the earlier papers i'm
most interested in are ones that are
more reflective of what i was doing at
the time
um so i really like the work of um
herb clark
uh who was a psycholinguistics
communication person
um and he did a lot of work that's um
that's easily ported to computational
models about how humans communicate um i
just i really loved his work in my
thesis i like cite like
all of his work
um
so yeah that's i guess that would be a
good set
it's a great answer
and we can link to all those too in the
show notes which will be nice for people
to check out
is there anything else you would like to
share or mention
about
the work that you're currently doing
or things you would like people to be
aware of one of the things that i'm
working on that others should work on i
think is around lowering the barrier uh
to entry for people from different
academic backgrounds to interrogate
systems
so we have a lot of people developing
technology
and that's great but we don't have a lot
of people who are
in a situation where they can really
question the technology because there's
often a bottleneck where for example if
you want to know about data
directly you have to be able to like log
into a server server and like right sql
query
so it's like there where the rubber
meets the road there's a bottleneck
where engineers have to do it and i want
to remove that bottleneck yeah so that's
a lot of the work i'm doing at hugging
face now like how can we take things
that are fundamentally
technical code stuff and open it up so
that thing is done under the hood and
people can directly query without
needing to know how to program yeah and
i think that's just in general we are
going to be able to make better
technology
when we remove the barriers that require
engineers to be
in the middle
absolutely what the work should be thank
you for um having me and interviewing me
it was very nice of you i appreciate it
i'll talk to you soon thanks alrighty
bye
so meg had a hard stop on the hour but i
was able to ask her my last question
offline which was
what's something you've been interested
in lately her response how to propagate
and grow plants in a synthetic
controlled environment
just when i thought she couldn't get any
cooler
you can keep up with meg on twitter i
will link to her twitter handle here and
we'll have it in the show notes
and i'm going to leave you with a
machine learning quote from a recent art
article that meg was quoted in saying
the most pressing problem is the
diversity and inclusion of who's at the
table from the start
all other issues fall out from there
thank you for listening to machine
learning experts if you or someone you
know is interested in direct access to
leading machining machine learning
experts like meg who are ready to help
accelerate your machine learning roadmap
please google expert acceleration
program or go to hf dot co
support to learn more thanks again for
joining us and i hope to see you next
time